they call them solidarity chains
female strength against police violence
and
mass detentions in belarus
for renata on the right it was her first
time to rebel
i will do peaceful women protest today
and another days because i understood
that
this is the part when i can be useful
where i can give something neighboring
lithuania wants to be useful
too its leader no longer recognizing
alexander lukashenko as president i
think
we cannot call mr lukashenko legitimate
because there were no free democratic
elections in belarus he's offered to
mediate a dialogue between the regime
and the opposition
along with latvia estonia and poland
if it will be not sufficient
or if you say okay if it will fail
fail then we will probably
start to look for other alternatives and
sanctions which could be imposed on
belarus
are also possible what role is russia
playing in all of this
russia is interested to have the
satellite state
and belarusia would be probably fully
integrated
into russia if we will stay passively
and if we will just be watching this
process
so our interest not only the interest of
lithuania but also the interest of
european union
is stable democratic and sovereign
belarus a fourth night of protests was
smaller than before
but this mutiny is real even workers
from state-run factories joining in
many see the main challenger in last
sunday's election as the true
president but she's in hiding in
lithuania
and one of the key women who supported
her fled to moscow
i would like to ask all international
community all the international leaders
not to acknowledge lukashenko is the
acting president
because he is illegitimate a bold
request
[Music]
but in belarus the chorus for change is
growing louder
[Music]
deborah haynes sky news vilnius